Washington State University is
suspending all fraternity and sorority
social events after the death of a
student possibly tied to alcohol this is
the fourth fraternity related death in
the u.s. in the past month that has led
to suspensions or crackdowns on
fraternities Jamie yuccas is in Los
Angeles for us Jamie so how bad is this
getting well Tony government researchers
say nearly 2000 college students die
each year from alcohol-related injuries
that includes car crashes fraternities
connecting the deaths have now also
occurred in San Diego New York and
Pennsylvania prompting a crackdown by
school officials police are still
investigating what happened at the Alpha
Tau Omega house off the Washington State
University campus where they received an
emergency call early Tuesday morning
medics arrived to find 19 year old
fraternity member Sam Martinez
unresponsive police say a preliminary
investigation indicated that his death
could be alcohol-related it sounds to me
that there's a cultural problem there is
a cultural problem
professor Hank Neuer has studied
fraternity drinking trends for decades
when the deaths occur it's often because
they not only want to drink with the
members they want to out drink them to
show off
Martinez's death comes days after 14
fraternities were suspended at San Diego
State University that followed the death
of 19 year old freshman Dylan Hernandez
who fell out of his bunk bed in his dorm
room and hit his head late last week
several students say Hernandez had been
drinking heavily at a fraternity party
in October Penn State suspended the Chi
fraternity as it investigates the death
of a 17 year old who is at an off-campus
house allegedly occupied by frat members
that same month Cornell University in
New York decried a pattern of misconduct
after the death of a student who earlier
attended of eternity event you start
wondering if sending your freshman to
colleges are going to be a dangerous
task
and and not something that you look
forward to as a parent the Washington
fraternities National Organization
offered condolences to Martinez's family
it says it's working with law
enforcement and the university in their
investigation now meanwhile San Diego
State has announced a task force to
review behaviors and procedures at the
school's Greek organizations Anthony
some really alarming numbers there Jimmy
thank you